right now
someone somewhere could be giving you a
score
a number that estimates how likely you
are to break the law
which tells police if they should zero
in on
you and which could forever change your
life
and the lives of those around you
it
it destroys everything
and this someone might not be a human
being but a computer so how do machines
try to predict crime and is it okay to
do that
from dw this is techtopia and in this
episode we are investigating how police
use technology to predict where crimes
will take place and who will commit them
we hear from officials about why they
use the systems
from experts who issued dire warnings
they do embed a lot of historical
discrimination
and we explain how the programs attempt
to forecast the future
and if that sounds like science fiction
to you well listen to this i feel like i
just got a stamp on my head with he's a
criminal watch out
this is damien when he was 14 years old
software flagged him to local police as
a future criminal
i committed a street robbery
and the reason i was put on the list
was that i committed another one on my
probation
my name is damian saraju and i live in
amsterdam
i was hanging with the wrong people but
you know
i didn't care i didn't think of the
consequences so damien did break the law
but he says that what happened after his
conviction
made it hard for him to get back on the
right path
what would have helped me is someone who
understood what i was going through i
don't think a computer system is
human enough to decide if you are going
on the list or not
that's how it all started
after damien was convicted for the two
robberies a computer program estimated
that he was likely to break the law
again that's why authorities put him on
a watch list called top 600
and they kept him on there after he had
served his sentence
[Music]
they actually didn't tell me what it
meant they were just like
i got an own sort of detective
and he tell me that if i would commit
any crime from that moment
he will be the first face i'll see in
the morning when they come to pick me up
to arrest me
i got id'd all the time
for no reason
you know you could be
trying your best to be not a criminal
and
they would point you at the smallest
thing you do what are you doing in this
neighborhood
i did feel trapped
i did feel like i was put in a box with
the top 600 logo on it and just put away
i didn't see a way out
and being on the list wouldn't only have
an impact on damien's life
it would also bring his brother who had
no criminal record into conflict with
the police and it would eventually lead
his mother to take on the entire system
confused no worries we'll get to the
bottom of that but first
let's start by looking into how the
technology works
at its heart there's a big promise to
stop crime before it's even committed
this is done by combing through masses
of data
some programs focus on potential crime
scenes
if they find links between previous
incidents say that they all occurred at
a certain time and place or even during
the same weather conditions
they recommend that police zero in on
those locations
other programs predict what they
consider to be potential offenders
they scan the criminal and personal
histories of individuals for risk
factors
such as who was arrested and how often
or even who dropped out of school
and come up with a list of who's likely
to break the law
[Music]
but how common is it for police to use
those systems
well it's actually more common than you
might think
over the last decade the use of
predictive policing has spread all
around the world
police in over 50 countries from western
democracies like france to authoritarian
nations like china now deploy the
programmes this has given rise to a
multi-billion dollar industry
with companies from small startups to
big corporations working on the programs
but those companies only build the
software the decision to use it is made
by policy makers often together with law
enforcement
and we wanted to find out why
in 2011 the then new mayor abraham milan
took office and in that period of time
amsterdam had to do with a lot of armed
robberies and violence out of the
streets and that caused great worries to
us and also to the inhabitants of
amsterdam
my name is hermann bolhar i'm the
national rapporteur on human trafficking
and sexual abuse of shielder
in 2011 i was a chief prosecutor in
amsterdam
we talked about new ways of dealing with
these problems and then
the idea of focusing
on the the hard core of offenders came
up
and then the idea of the top 600
was
born we got together and came to the
conclusion that we should do more to
analyze what was really going on and try
to see what we could do to be more
preventative
because if you prevent it from happening
then there are no victims and no
perpetrators right
over a decade later the top 600 is still
up and running along with a second list
called top 400 which was introduced in
2015
well the top 100 is the little brother
of the top 600.
my name is martin skippers i'm the chief
information officer of the public order
and safety department of the city of
amsterdam 100 top 600 are our proven
criminals top 400 are those at high risk
at getting in that direction to recap
the city of amsterdam now has two lists
one that's called top 600 for those
who've already been convicted of crimes
and a second one called top 400 for
teenagers deemed likely to become
criminals
for example in the top 600 you would
have to be arrested for high impact
crimes a couple of times in the last
couple of years
if the software finds that a person has
also been convicted more than once it
recommends putting them on the top 600.
for the top 400 the software is looking
at more than just the criminal records
of teenagers checking also if they have
a history of domestic abuse
if they have serious problems at school
or if they've ever been on the radar of
youth care
these are all criteria so say from one
to ten and you have to fit say at least
seven
and then then you will be put on the top
400 or top 600 list
the aim is on on the one side solving a
societal problem solving a safety
problem making the city safer but also
trying to create a little bit of a
better life for a portion of our
population
that never really had the chances or the
opportunities
that's the strategy behind the programs
in amsterdam
first use technology to identify those
most at risk of breaking the law
and then boost both strict oversight by
police as well as support by social
workers to prevent them from committing
crimes so much for the theory now the
question is does it work
when damien was 14
i heard of the top 600 list but it
didn't say much to me
i just read about it that it would help
your son
to get
back on track
my name is diana sergio and i'm the
mother of damien
it didn't work out for us as well as we
thought it it destroyed everything
and we're not a family anymore it
destroyed it it pulls us apart
they put his
older brother
he's one year older on the listen for
400 just out of
yeah precaution
because they say from yeah if one of the
kids is on the 600 that most likely will
influence the other kids in the family
it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy
you know you put him on the list he's
not a criminal yet but he will get there
so they labeled him
and because of that
he thinks okay is that what they think
from me and i will act that way
what diana says about her two sons here
sums up the core controversy over
predictive policing
ask supporters and they tell you that
the technology can help build a society
where crime is nipped in the bud
but opponents say the systems do the
opposite and often target the most
vulnerable members of society pushing
them even further to the edges
the programs for instance often flag
low-income communities or minority
neighborhoods as alleged hotspots
prompting the police to patrol those
areas more than others
this in turn generates even more data
and sets of a vicious circle of
discrimination flagging these areas over
and over again
similarly the programs tend to single
out low-income people
and minorities as potential offenders
but why is that why do computers
replicate the kind of biases we know
from the analog world existing police
data whether in new delhi whether in the
u.s whether in germany whether in
australia embed a lot of historical
discrimination
they do embed systemic problems such as
racism or castism or even sexism now
we're taking all of this data
that is you know seemingly objective and
correct but is in reality quite biased
and discriminated especially towards
minority populations we take that as
being the ground truth on which the
computer kind of like learns what
patterns exist
you know i always learned one thing in
school the computer doesn't make
mistakes people do
it's what you put in it that will come
out
and
years later
and i'm now
older and somehow that came to mind
again i said yeah but if
they put wrong data
feed the computer wrong data then we can
get a whole thing that isn't right
you need to take care of poverty
good education
and equal
chances
her criticism is that with this program
you are fighting the symptoms rather
than the root cause of crime
maybe yeah sometimes every case of the
600 is very different
and with some you can only fight the
symptoms
with some you don't even get to the
symptoms you know sometimes you just
really don't get far at all
and sometimes you get closer you can get
deeper and you can actually help with
the root causes so who's right
the city officials who say that their
program helps prevent crime or damien's
mother diana who says that it does the
opposite
well let's take a look at what the
research says does predictive policing
work we don't know we don't know well we
did a
broad literature review of publications
about predictive policing to investigate
to what extent we know whether
predictive policing works
but also to what extent it results in
adverse effects but what we found out is
that there is actually very little
empirical evidence it's more ideological
than empirically based the interesting
thing is that predictive policing is
introduced so widely as if it would be
very effective whereas we argue that
there really is no strong basis for this
assertion but as public awareness for
the risks of predictive policing is
growing
we've identified two trends in our
investigation
one is that after a series of police
killings ignited a debate over systemic
racism and how to reform policing in the
u.s police departments from santa cruz
to los angeles abandoned their
predictive policing efforts
[Music]
which raises the question could that
push back that first trend be a global
trend
i would want to say yes but
unfortunately my answer is very much a
no in countries that don't have strong
data protection legislation or you know
where governments are more open to
experimenting with technologies on
people we see that predictive policing
is actually on the rise the second trend
we've noticed is that many companies
have moved away from forecasting who
will commit crimes to where they will
take place
this they say makes their systems less
prone to discrimination
but
are they
no they are just as prone to
discrimination so place-based predictive
policing systems essentially take a
bunch of data whether that can be
historical arrest data or how many
people rent in a given neighborhood how
close you are to
um drug counseling centers and use all
that input to guess where they think
crime will happen
and what's been found time and time
again is that it simply sends police to
the various places that they've already
policed in the past so if experts tell
us that predictive policing is prone to
discrimination
then what does the law say about its use
governments are deploying tools without
any sort of law in place to
allow individuals that are affected by
those technologies to have appropriate
remedies there needs to be more exposure
about what tools are being used but
there also need to be avenues for
challenging not only the decisions that
are being made by those computers but
also in certain instances having a
opportunity to
abandon the use of the technology
entirely in 2020 damien's hometown of
amsterdam
introduced an online registry where it
lists all algorithms used by its public
administration we want to show people
this is what we do so if you're on the
top 600 you can always in that register
very simply look up
what it is that we did with your data
and how we came to the conclusion to put
you on the list or not and speaking of
damien did he ever get off that list
i did get off the list
it took me three years
you broke the law
weren't you just paying a fair price
for that
yeah i think i already paid my price
when i got sentenced for you know the
things i've done i've got my house
arrest my
evening clock
you know
i even had some fines i think that
or i know that i already learned my
lesson from that
i expected my mom to turn her back on me
because
you know
i felt like i was the black sheep
what i did
was the worst and could not be forgiven
but she
actually stood aside me
i was the first
mother who stepped out in public
in the newspaper full name full face
and told about my experience on the top
600 list i was the only one who was
speaking up because the other ones were
afraid
to speak up i think it helped also that
i went public
that he got after this
and when diana realized that there were
many other families like hers she
decided to take her fight to the next
level and set up a foundation
i started at my kitchen table
you know i
i
got money together in the beginning
nobody would listen to me
but here after three years
i'm still here
and i'm helping mothers all over the
country now
things are changing slowly but they're
changing step by step
and yet police departments around the
world continue to use software to
predict crimes and who will commit them
which brings us back to our key question
when is it okay to use predictive
policing
it has to be clear
how the police makes certain choices
about
about
the allocation of its resources we need
to know what kind of data are being used
by these algorithms what kind of rules
are being coded in these algorithms and
we have to ensure that the police does
not work in a discriminatory manner
predictive policing should never be used
it has been shown time and time again to
be discriminatory technology is not
always the answer to problems sometimes
the answer doesn't lie in technology but
maybe in rethinking institutions in
rebuilding institutions in figuring out
where institutions have gone wrong
predictive policing our investigation
showed us remains one of the most
controversial technologies of our time
whether or not to use it is up to
lawmakers to decide but all experts we
talked to agreed that if they decide to
use it clear rules are needed and it's
time to debate how those rules should
look like unlike the early systems like
the one that flagged damien
newer ones make it increasingly
difficult or even impossible to
understand how exactly they come up with
their predictions predictions that as
we've seen
can have life-altering consequences
and when it comes to decisions like that
what do you think
should a machine have the last word
[Music]
you